The idea began in the year 2014 exactly.
2014 was during the events in Gaza and the events
in the West Bank were
confrontations everywhere in all the governorates of Palestine and all
parts of Palestine.
One day I took gas
and thought I would do something with it so that it would mean
getting rid of the oppression and the oppression that was being done inside him through
this channel that  Workers beat it in the camp and
[Music] There is
no one who comes with me except that I serve with him, Akram Lazm,
because this place is for me. I mean, I
consider it a real message. How much we are a
silent and patient people, and we hope for our rights, and we have hope, and
I cling to life, it is impossible
[Music]